Luke here with the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and I'm in the Appalachian
Mountains and I'm doing Frontier style
survival and Bushcraft camping and I'm
bringing you along for the ride
all right guys time to go do some
camping
just saw a decent sized Black Bear right
in front of my car into the bushes
foreign
welcome to the Appalachian Mountains of
West Virginia it's the first cool day of
fall and we're going to be doing some
Frontier style hiking and camping
tell you what the weather is so
deceptive today it is absolutely
gorgeous but it's supposed to get down
to 40 degrees tonight and we got wind
gusts of 15 miles per hour it's going to
be cold I'm gonna need a good Shelter
tonight
these leather straps are very functional
but they cut into your shoulder I got a
long ways to go I think I better put
some padding there
oh that feels worlds better
oh look at that guys
that my friends is black bear poop
there's definitely black bears around
here
oh that's pretty
I got across this stream but I don't
want to get my feet wet it'll give me
blisters bad I think I might be able to
hop across the stones Upstream a little
bit
oh I'm getting a little thirsty
in case you're wondering it's just water
just water
oh
aha
you know I'm not sure what berry this is
I'm gonna look it up when I get home
it's got yellow gooey flesh with about
half a dozen big seeds
oh look at that
[Music]
oh well they didn't like me sticking my
camera in there if I was in a survival
situation I could knock that Nest down
run like the devil and come back the
next day or in like 12 hours the Wasps
will abandon the nest and then you can
pick out all the pupas I've never eaten
wasp larva before but I've destroyed my
fair share of wasps nest and unless that
size could have a lot of larva in it
a lot of mushrooms in these mountains
but the spring and fall in these
mountains is a great time to find
mushrooms
foreign
s that well I know morels chanterelles
puffballs chicken of the woods that's
about it
look at that
there's like a foot and a half deep pile
of leaves here it is really luxurious
oh this is pretty nice oh this is a
tough call this is about two hours and
two miles before I was gonna start
looking for a campsite but this is
pretty awesome there's such an enormous
pile of dry leaves here it's really soft
and with this rock acting as a heat
reflector if I built a campfire here I'd
be so warm
I need to eat some lunch while I think
about this
add some cheese and dried dates love it
I always bring way too much food on
these campouts like going to bed hungry
is not an option for me
I love my water flask took some doing to
get it 100 water tight but uh hasn't
dropped a drip all day I know it's a
risk but I want to go find a different
campsite as comfy as this would be I
really would like some place a little
closer to some water
all right
here's another campsite that wouldn't be
too bad it's flat dry sheltered no water
this is weird this looks like the
remnants of an underground forest fire
all the trees over here look like
they've been burned below the soil line
but only below the soil line Looks Like
The Roots have been burned but the
tree's still alive
I mean that's charcoal right there I've
heard about forest fires smoldering
underground that's weird looking
hey look what I found
I think that's somebody's pepper spray
somebody must have dropped this while
they were getting eaten by a bear yeah
oh yep
ain't no bears taking advantage of me
tonight
quite a few spider webs on this Trail I
don't think anyone's watched this for at
least a few days
I'm just getting coded in spider webs
that was a big one there's another one
well there's another one every three or
four feet I'm going through a spider web
hold this stick out in front of you let
it clear out all the spider webs
[Music]
ite
yeah
that was deeper than it looks
I'm starting to wonder whether passing
up on that last campsite was a good idea
a lot of putrid water and swampy ground
here
see how Brown this water is just means
it's full of tannin which is the
chemical that leeches out of decomposing
leaves I'm not 100 sure what vegetation
is responsible for the tannin but often
where I see rhododendrons I'll often see
brown water like this
foreign
check out all this Moss here
pull this up
look at that it's clean drinking water
right there
tastes super earthy but it's clean
well I'd hope to have a campsite by now
well there's a little stream
see all the bubbles he's got to get that
frothiness whenever you get a lot of
tanning in the water
oh
look at this spot
I just realized I'm really tired even
though it looks pretty flat it's not
there's some pretty big rocks underneath
the leaves so I'm gonna see if I can't
move some rocks around and make this a
little bit more level
oh
I think this is gonna work well I think
what I need to do next is pile up as
many dry leaves as I can and I need to
clear out a spot for my fire and make a
little fire pit and a heat reflector for
the fire
When You're Building A Fire like this
safety is a pretty big issue and I don't
want to start a forest fire so there's a
couple things I got going for me first
off it's really wet right here under the
ledge there's all these drips coming off
the edge of the rock so it's perpetually
wetting this section here so a fire is
not likely to spread if I build a modest
fire and keep an eye on it this should
be okay if I want to cook two meals boil
a bunch of water and stay warm tonight
so I'm gonna need a ton of wood oh loads
of stuff on the ground is so soggy
foreign
that's not a huge pile of wood but it's
enough to get me started
there you go you can see how much
tannins in there the tannin doesn't make
it unsafe to drink it just makes it
taste funny but you still have to boil
it in case there's bacteria in there
all right now we need some Tinder got
this ultra thin Ultra dry Pine that's
what we want
[Music]
foreign
all right here's my fire kit
I got a piece of Steel a piece of flint
some shirted up jute and a char cloth
I'm gonna put this
inside
that jute
I'm sticking too much wood on top of the
fire and it's causing all this smoke
because it's smothering the fire but I'm
doing that because all the woods damp
and I want it to dry out
almost all this wood is wet so I'm just
stacking it up here in the fire ring to
dry it out
even though I'm using Frontier style
equipment on this trip I've got a few
modern things with me I've got my Garmin
inreach mini so I can send and receive
text messages and my wife can track my
location it's good for safety I also
have a headlamp because I need to be
able to film at night I also have about
two or three pounds of GoPro batteries
backup cameras and GoPro mounts in my
bag
this water is going to be clean but it's
going to have a bit of a funny taste so
I brought this it's for making tea you
unscrew it
you just put a little loose leaf tea in
there you can Harvest berries and herbs
that you find along the way put it in
there and make tea out of it and in this
case I've got a peach lemon herbal tea
in there those of you guys who watch my
channel might recognize my mug I made
this out of cow horn a couple years ago
and did a video on it my tea steeper
hooked around the handle there
just let that steep for about five
minutes or so just sit that over there
this is salted fat back bacon lasts a
long time even without Refrigeration so
you can carry it around in your pack
makes great seasoning and stew
and put my potatoes in there throw that
meat in there between the grease and all
the seasoning on the fat back it's going
to give a lot of flavor to this stew
got some carrots there all right got
some bulb onions here
got a bundle of chives here
little soups and stews like this are
pretty awesome because pretty much
anything you find that you can eat you
can throw in the stew whether it's a
squirrel or some herbs or a mushroom or
whatever I always bring way too much
food and I brought along some beef jerky
and you can throw that in your stew too
it has lots of flavor lots of protein
all right it's coming along pretty good
needs a few more minutes got some raw
sugar for my tea here
I'm a little bit cold tired and thirsty
and this tea just hits the spot
tastes even better when you drink it out
of a cowhorn mug you made yourself
while I wait for my soup to simmer I
think I'm gonna go get some more
firewood it's gonna be really cold
tonight
[Applause]
foreign
like the soup it's tasting good
add just a little
pinch of flour oh that stew smells
amazing looks perfect and smell the
chives and the onions and the Bacon fat
oh it's so hot
I could see my breath but this stew is
hitting the spot
I'm just gonna boil up some water and
fill up my canteen and have some water
ready for the morning
for those of you that watch my videos
you won't be surprised I brought a
little bag of flour here to make some
bread I'm gonna be doing that in the
morning so I'm gonna go ahead and add my
yeast and water and get it ready and so
it can rise overnight
I'm gonna add my sugar
we're gonna add some whole wheat bread
flour
my bag has a ton of holes in it
hey
they just let that sit and Rise till
morning
time to get ready for bed
I'm just gonna hang out here by the fire
before I go to sleep but notice I folded
the blanket over I've done this so that
the inside layer won't get covered in
leaves and that's the layer I'm going to
wrap around myself so I don't get poked
by leaves that night these blankets just
attract leaves like crazy
a moment of your time I think it's time
to go to bed I'm gonna go and put my
blanket on this nice pile of leaves here
and
try to get some sleep
having a fire under this outcropping is
making such a huge difference it feels a
good 10 degrees warmer here
but it's late and I need to get to go in
the bed I'll see you guys in the morning
good morning it's early and I do not
want to get up
but it's cold and the fire's going out
nicer I need to cook up some breakfast
I'll tell you what I stayed warmer than
I expected but man that ground was hard
so for breakfast I've got seasoned pork
jowls and I got this lump of dough I've
got some honey and butter to put on it
we're gonna oil up this rock
we're just gonna take this whole slab of
pork gels and just lay it right there on
the rock
foreign
there we go some butter on this
a little honey and butter on fried
flatbread man it's hard to be a nice
piece of pork gel bacon
foreign
it's completely out
[Music]
this little flask has been great it's
about a liter and a half and it's just
worked wonderfully and if you wanted to
build something like this at home it's a
really easy project to do requires very
little tools and all you need is some
beeswax leather and a piece of wood
really
foreign
somebody left their doordash
foreign
that sure was a fun trip I hope you guys
enjoyed that if you guys want to see
more videos from the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel check out our Campion
Adventure playlist I'll put a link in
the video description below and make
sure to click subscribe we put out new
videos every Saturday morning thanks for
watching guys we'll see you next
Saturday if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning hit that Bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]